let's get the view from the government
now on the cost of living crisis at the
minister for policing kit malthouse
joins us once again on the programme
minister it's good to see you this
morning and um
the reason i say so whenever we have
chatted in the past you know you
compared to some of your colleagues have
always been prepared to be quite candid
about what is going on and at a moment
like this i think the public deserves a
little bit of candor
how bad
are things about to get for a large
number of britons
well obviously as as you quite rightly
say it's very tough at the moment uh we
completely acknowledge that the the
combination of factors that you outlined
uh in your run-up to this
uh interview has meant that prices are
rising significantly energy prices in
particular driven by a variety of
factors post pandemic the war in ukraine
you know other kind of global factors
outside of our immediate control and it
is tough uh you know for those of us who
have a smart meter as as we do here in
my house you know we can see how much
it's costing us on an hourly basis and
it is uh
not happy reading um having said that uh
obviously
uh notwithstanding the the rise in the
national insurance threshold that you um
the rise in the national insurance rate
that you just outlined there are other
measures that the chancellor's taken to
try and help uh with some of the cost of
living
uh problems so you know the cut and fuel
duty obviously the national insurance
threshold will be raised from july
that's worth about 300 quid a year to
sort of 30 million working people across
the country we've got this household
support fund now a billion pounds that's
targeting those in real need across the
whole of england and wales and then of
course the other thing to bear in mind
that that happens today of course is the
national living wage rises by six point
six percent to nine pounds fifty which
is the largest rise i think uh uh for
some time and that should be about a
thousand pounds a year uh for a
full-time worker so while it is tough
obviously the chancellor's trying to do
his best to ameliorate a challenge
although we can't go all the way and
ameliorate at all i'm afraid
no no but some would question why
a lot of the assistance appears to have
been targeted at those who are perhaps
not most in need i mean the estimates
vary but a kind of a ballpark figure
appears to be like one in three pounds
announced by the chancellor in the
spring statement going to the bottom
half of the income distribution
why are we spending two out of three on
the top half
well i'm not sure would necessarily uh
characterize it that way we are
targeting lots of the assistance at
people at the lower end of the wage
distribution so whether that's the rise
of the national living wages household
support fund billion pounds now being
targeted and then of course raising the
national insurance threshold uh helps
them too and don't forget uh the change
in the universal credit taper for those
who are in receipt of universal credit
but also working that's worth about a
thousand pounds a year so when you take
it in the round you know i think you'll
find it is skewed towards the bottom end
albeit we want to try and help as many
people as possible within the financial
constraints that we've got it's worth
remembering as well of course that one
of the biggest uh helps is to be in work
and obviously uh levels of employment
are at an all-time high at the moment
you're talking about payroll presumably
you're not talking about numbers and
what because we're comparing numbers and
numbers actually but this is this is a
mistake that the government has
repeatedly made
for whatever purpose but actually if
we're talking about the numbers of
people in work at the moment we're
talking several hundred thousand fewer
than they were at the start of the
pandemics like let's just part that for
a second what specifically though are we
doing for those people who are not
earning a wage are those people who are
on such low incomes that they are still
in receipt of universal credit we have
seen a small percentage point rise in
universal credit but one which will i'm
sure you will agree be utterly dwarfed
by the inflation which we will
experience this year
well obviously the the key targeting
mechanism is this household support fund
you know we had it at half a billion
pounds was very successful local
authorities targeting that money at
those most in need at the lower end of
the economic uh scale we've doubled that
now uh to a billion pounds and obviously
hopefully um we have got a high number
of vacancies in the economy hopefully
they can work with their uh
department of work and pensions work
coaches to get into work and benefit
from that change in the taper you know
we want to see everyone what if they
don't what if they can't
what if they can't find a job i mean on
the one hand we're saying you know we're
seeing almost record employment you also
say just a moment ago there are lots of
job vacancies out there so i'm slightly
confused but for those people who do not
have a job right now or for example a
single mother working 20 hours a week on
receipt of universal credit she will be
poured her off as a result of the
changes made by the chancellor
well as i say if she's struggling then
there's the household support fund that
she can uh look to obviously
which is finite
it is finite but it's very targeted you
know it's a billion pounds that's being
targeted and as we move into the to the
rest of the year obviously the
chancellor is going to monitor the
situation very closely um and think
about what more we may be able to do to
help and he signaled that in the past
look neil you are quite right we are we
are facing a a very difficult global
situation here driven by
external factors outside the country at
the same time we're facing a very
challenging financial situation
internally having spent you know
billions and millions of pounds getting
ourselves through the pandemic in in
good shape what we're trying to do is
balance that situation help as many
people as we can with what we
acknowledge is a very tough uh situation
at the moment and then hope that over
time things will improve from an
inflation and a fuel price point of view
and we can get back onto the onto the
path to prosperity
the chancellor describes the policy
initiatives that he's brought forward as
as progressive what does he mean by that
i just want to focus for a second on on
the council tax rebate i will be in
receipt of that you may well be in
receipt of that i'm just going to gently
suggest that if a breakfast television
news presenter is in receipt of funding
it's not a progressive policy i don't
need it
well
i mean obviously everybody is suffering
from the the fuel price uh uh rise uh
lots of people need i'm not assistance
yeah but we are we also uh pumping the
the council tax bill into people at band
a uh in particular and then grading it
over time so we're trying to give
now a kind of balanced package
of assistance across the whole of the
economy right now whether that is
targeting money at people who are really
struggling through the household support
fund or providing widespread relief
through the raise in the national
insurance professional we're trying to
give a balanced package across the whole
of the economy because people are
struggling different ways you know if
you are a
family of uh two parents with children
you've got significant extra costs
compared to a single person living alone
so we need to make sure that we have a
very balanced package that gives as much
assistance as we can within the
constraints that we've got
let's take just a couple of the measures
we're talking about there i mean
national insurance i get it if you
expand at the bottom that does mean
fewer people are paying tax but what of
those who aren't at that threshold point
already chancellor made an awful lot
about the current fuel duty when he was
at the dispatch box again if you look at
the numbers those at the very bottom end
55 percent of the bottom demographic
don't drive these measures do not help i
mean are you are you entirely confident
that the chancellor a man who on a
treasury organized photo opportunity
couldn't work out how to pay for petrol
at the pump
are you in any way confident that this
is a man who genuinely knows what it is
like to be counting the pennies in your
pocket
i am yes and i think that's unfair on
him you've got to remember the great
advantage uh of our system is that all
of us as mps are anchored in our
constituencies right and we sit down as
i will be later today in a constituency
surgery and we deal with our
constituents on a daily basis with the
very
huge variety of issues and problems that
we had so notwithstanding our own uh
particular situation financially
obviously we have you know heavy
exposure to how everybody across the
whole of the
of course of course i'm talking about
this individual ability to empathize
with people at the bottom end of society
i mean this this is a chancellor that
thought there was a debate about whether
or not to give poor kids food during the
summer holidays
well as i say i think that's unfair the
chancellor is trying to do a very
difficult thing which is to balance the
requirements of the british people for
assistance at a time of need against the
long-term financial health of the whole
country right we we've just come through
a pandemic where we had to spend 400
billion plus to keep the economy on
track that work that he did has kept
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
people
in work and kept you know them going uh
through one of the most difficult things
we've faced in this country since the
second world war that was a massively
challenging job and he pulled it off uh
with enormous skill and dexterity of
course he's in touch with the problems
of the british people and that's why we
brought in the measures work that we've
had but as he's said uh just to think
yesterday right that the constraints of
the national economy mean that we can't
solve every problem we have to monitor
the situation everyone understands that
everyone understands that i'm sorry
financially as we can to help as many
people as we can okay then why on earth
then are we starting today to charge
people for lateral flow tests we've both
conceded a moment ago that genuinely
people are literally counting the
pennies in their pockets if it is a
toss-up between spending two pounds in
food for your kids or two pounds in a
lateral flow test we both know which way
people's priorities will go why are we
making people right now choose between
putting food in their kids belly and
working out whether or not they've got
covered
well that's because obviously we're
moving to situation uh as the prime
minister's outline where we we have to
now live with covet um and deal with it
commissions are running as high as
they've been this year minister yeah i
know i understand that i just had it
myself a couple of weeks ago as as the
rest of my family so we've had impact at
home too um look we're moving towards
living with govid the lateral flow test
has come to absolute fortune um every
month
we believe now that we can sort of get
on with normalizing society not
withstanding the rising infections that
we've seen i'm not asking you to pay for
everyone i'm not asking you to pay for
my for my lateral flow test i'm lucky
enough to work for a company that
provides them i'm asking you to perhaps
provide them i don't know to people on
universal credit
well as i say the the decision has been
made at the department of health the
cost of it didn't justify the effect
ongoing that we're learning to live with
covid obviously we're now rolling out as
you know the fourth booster uh to those
people most vulnerable um so we we now
have to live with this uh disease i'm
afraid and that means that free lateral
flows are coming to an end given the
cost benefit analysis i guess that the
treasury has done
i i do want to ask just as we wrap up
about the energy strategy the depending
energy strategy
when will that be published i understand
that everyone in government has an
absolute ton on their plate at the
moment but the simple truth of the
matter is you are wrestling with the
energy strategy back when boris johnson
became prime minister when greg clark
was the business and energy secretary
there was a debate ongoing then about
nuclear power and how to fund it when
are we going to get the detail on this
well as i understand it there's
obviously intensive conversations going
on particularly accelerated in the light
of the of the ukraine
exacerbation if you like of the global
energy situation and and i think that
strategy will be appearing i gather
shortly um it's obviously a big and
extensive uh document that needs
consideration and there's some big
financial strategic decisions that need
to be made so i'm not surprised that
it's taking just a little bit more time
than was anticipated um hopefully it'll
be next week but let's see
is this as it's been pretty widely
reported because the prime minister and
the chancellor has on so many issues at
the moment cannot come to agreement on
nuclear power
well i'm not close to the conversation
to be honest with you but i don't know
but given the scale of the strategic
decisions that are being made i hope the
british people would want their
politicians to be really chewing on this
issue uh very extensively and seriously
and having intensive discussions about
what the right track is for the future i
think it's now accepted
that governments of previous generations
possibly made an error in not investing
in nuclear but these are huge
investments required for the future of
our power and fuel security and so it's
right that we take time to just get the
decisions correct okay it's great to
have you on the program this morning
really appreciate your time